- Ya'll tryna watch some of
them Summer Games tonight?
- Hell yeah, the Dream Team
playing.
- How it gon' be a Dream
Team without LeBron?
- More like a Lean Team, ain't
no way
they winning the gold without
the King.
- I heard Bron Bron didn't wanna
go to Rio de Ja-Negro because of
Zika.
- Zika, you mean that big booty
mami
who be popping it on her snaps?
- Nah, it's like the Brazilian
ebola.
It's supposed to make your head
shrink.
- Man, Zika ain't real, Brazil
made that shit up so they
could win some medals.
- Ain't nobody tryna
watch basketball anyway,
I stay on that gymnastics.
- Yeah those dudes is super
huff,
but I ain't tryna see all them
mamel toes.
- I'm talkin' bout women's
gymnastics.
Them leotards they wear be
showcasing them bush knuckles.
- Yea but gymnast bodies too
compact.
Only Brazilian volleyball
booty can handle this nine.
(all laughing)
- What about ice skating though?
- That's the Winter Games,
dumbass!
- Damn, why they gotta
segregate?
- I'ma segregate yo'
asses to the parking lot
if ya'll don't get yo
motherfuckin' heads in the game!
- Can't you see us conversating,
damn, have some manners.
- Bunch of ungrateful ass
mothafuckas!
- [All] Mark!
(all laughing)
(high-pitched laughing)
- [Voiceover] Legends, work.